got it did you know that only two and
five kiwis feel that they're well
prepared for a disaster
weather events in our district have been
getting more frequent and more severe
but many of us are still in the dark
about how to prepare and what to do
during an event
weather warnings are issued by the Met
service and they tell us what to expect
during an extreme weather event the
camps alerts residents of relevant
warnings via our website and social
media we then provide updates on
anything that's relevant to our local
area for more detailed information and
to put together a plan for your whanau
visit getready.govt.nz
foreign